did want to ask
[Music]
um during the 360 era of gears and I
know you spoke one very highly of Rod
right and salute to The Legend
um I wanted to ask about peterbor
in that era like you know how was it
interacting with him during that era you
know obviously 360s tried to come on the
scene establish itself and then also you
know were you part of the decision
because gears was so vital for 360 were
you part of that decision for like what
is it the 512 Ram uh decision as far as
what gears could look like yeah so yeah
the whole like uh you know adding extra
memory to the Xbox 360. that was uh Mark
rain and Tim Sweeney basically put their
foot down okay at the time it was Shane
Kim that was actually the one who's
responsible for those decisions but
Peter Moore is an absolute gentleman and
a scholar he is an absolute I I can't
say that word but he's just a bad MF
he he's the kind of guy that can